we spend the last few lectures
developing the theory of graph limits
and one of the motivations I gave at the
beginning of the lecture on graph lines
was that there were certain graph
inequalities specifically if I tell you
that your graph has edge density 1/2
what's the minimum possible c4 density
okay so for those kinds of problems
graph limits gives us a very nice
language for describing what the answer
is I also sometimes for solving these
problems so today I want to dive more
into these types of problems
specifically we're going to be talking
about homomorphism density inequalities
so trying to understand what is the
relationship between possible sub graph
densities or homomorphism densities
within a large graph we've seen this
kind of problems in the past so one of
the very first theorems that we did in
this course was Terron Sturm and
men-tel's theorem so specifically for
mental serum it tells us something about
possible edge versus triangle densities
in the graph which is something that I
want to spend the first part of today's
lecture focusing on so what is the
possible relationship what are all the
possible edge versus ten edge versus
triangle densities in a graph main house
theorem tells us something namely that
if your edge density exceeds one half
then your triangle density cannot be 0
so that's what men-tel's theorem tells
us and let me write it down like this so
the statement I just said the one that
bought me Intel stay
and more generally for Terron student
tells us that if the K R + 1 density W
is 1 0 then necessarily the edge density
is at most 1 minus 1 over R so this is
what it tells us it gives us some
information about what are the possible
densities but I would like to know you
know more generally or a complete
picture of what is a set of H verses
triangle density inequalities so let me
draw a picture that is captures what
we're looking for so here is on the
x-axis I have all the possible edge
densities and on the vertical axis I
have the triangle density and I would
like to know what is the set of feasible
points in this box then tells theorem
tells us already something namely when
can you so this this region 0 the
horizontal lying at 0 extends and most
until the halfway point beyond this
point it's not a part of the feasible
region so so far that's the information
that we know our discussion about graph
limits and in particular ok so let me
first write down what is the question so
if you look at the set of possible edge
vs. triangle densities okay so there's
this region here what is this region so
it's a subset of this unit square
we would like to understand what is the
set of all possibilities become practice
of the space of griffons tells us that
this region is compact so let me call
this region d23 for triangle versus edge
versus triangle so dq3 is compact
because the space of graph founders
compact under the cut metric and
densities are continuous under cut
distance so in particular you if you
have some limit point of some sequence
of graphs that limit points achieved by
a corresponding limit graph all okay so
you really have a nice closed region
over here all right so we don't have to
you know should be able to tell with the
answer's no this is a region there
should not be any additional quantifiers
no optimizer zero missing this point
missing that pole is a closed region
okay so what is this closed region
equivalent me we can ask the following
question
suppose I give you the edge density in
other words look at a particular
horizontal place in this picture what is
the maximum and minimum possible
triangle densities
okay so I tell you that the edge density
is 0.75 what is the upper and lower
boundaries of this region I want you to
think about why this region is the
vertical cross section is a line segment
you cannot have any holes it's a bet
that requires an argument and then I'll
let you think about that okay so I want
to complete this picture and I'll show
you some proofs and at the end of what
by the middle of today's lecture we'll
see a picture of what this region looks
like alright first let me do the easier
direction which is to find the upper
boundary of this region so what is the
maximum possible triangle density for a
given edge density and the the answer
okay so it turns out to be what hour the
result I'll tell you it's a special case
of what's called cruise car cattle now
think about it this way suppose I give
you a very large number of vertices and
I give you some large number of edges
and I want you to put the edges into the
graph in a way that generates as many
triangles as possible intuitively how
should you put the edges in to try to
make as many triangles as you can in a
click so you put all the edges as
closely together as possible try to form
a clique so maximize number of triangles
by forming a creek
and now this indeed the answer and this
is what we'll proof at least in the
graph densities version so we will show
that the upper boundary is given by the
curve y equals to X to the three half
which okay so don't worry about the
specific function but what's important
is that the upper bound is achieved by
the following graph Oh namely there's
the graph on corresponding to a clique
for this graph on here the edge density
is a squared and the triangle density is
a cube and it turns out this graph on is
the best that you can do with a given
edge density in order to generate as
many triangles or the most triangle
density possible or in other words we'll
proof is that the triangle density so
throughout W will be a graph oh sorry W
is always a graph on so values between 0
& 1 then you have the following
inequality okay so let's prove it
but first let me draw you what this
shape looks like
because of the relationship between
graphs and graph limits any of these
inequalities about graph limits about
griffons it's sufficient to prove the
corresponding inequality for graphs
right because the set of graphs is dense
within the space of griffons according
to the topology maybe the cut metric
that we discussed so it suffices to show
corresponding inequality about graphs
namely that the k3 density in the graph
is at most K 2 pencil T in the graph
raised to the power 3 half okay so let
me pull label this point out just a
little bit more this inequality is a
subset of those inequalities up there
because graphs sit inside a space of
griffons but because they sit inside in
a dense dense subset if you know this
inequality and everything is continuous
then you know that inequality so these
two are equivalent to each other now
with graphs and specifically these
counts here okay so triangle densities
and edge densities they correspond to
counting closed walks in the graph so in
particular if we're interested in the
cave number of k3 homomorphisms in the
graph this is the same as counting
closed walks of length 3 and there was
an important identity we used earlier
when we were discussing the proof of
quasi random graphs that for counting
closed walks you should look at the
spectral moment so that's a very
important tool to look at the spectral
moment maybe here the third power of the
eigenvalues of the adjacency matrix
office
this is TV I can values of the adjacency
matrix I claim that this sum here is
upper bounded by a corresponding sum of
squares raised to the power that
normalizes the first time I saw this I
was a bit confused because I remember
how our maintaining quality shouldn't go
the other way but actually not this is
the correct direction so let me let me
remind you why so if you have positive T
then playing that and you have a bunch
of no negative Rios then the claim is
that this teeth power sum is less than
or equal to the teeth power saw now
there are several ways to to see why
this is true you can do induction but
let me show you one way which is quite
neat because it's homogeneous in the
variables I can assume that the sum is
one in which case the left hand side is
equal to this sum of teeth powers and so
because I assumed that everything is
non-negative
everything is all these aids are between
0 and 1 so now the sum is less than or
equal to same sum without the T's which
is the right
okay so so this is true and now we have
this sum of square surf eigenvalues
which is also a moment of the moment of
the eigenvalues namely corresponding to
K 2 so the same inequality is true for
graph homomorphisms and to get to the
inequality for densities we just divide
by the number of vertices raised to the
third power on both sides and and we get
inequality that we're looking for okay
so that's the proof of the upper dog any
questions there is something that
bothers me slightly about this look it's
a correct proof so there's nothing
nothing wrong with this proof everything
is kosher everything is correct you
might ask is there a way to do this
spectral argument in graph phones you
know without passing two graphs and yes
you can because for graph phones you can
also talk about a spectrum it turns out
to be a compact operator so its spectrum
makes sense you have to develop a little
bit more theory about the spectrum of
compact operators but everything more or
less works exactly the same way it's
just easier to talk about graphs but
what bothers me about this proof is that
we started with what I would call a
physical inequality meaning that it only
has to do with the actual edges and sub
graph densities but the proof involved
going to the spectrum and that bothers
me a little bit then there's nothing
incorrect about it but somehow in my
mind a physical inequality deserves a
physical proof so physical I use the
word
physical in contrast to frequency which
is coming from Fourier analysis and
that's the next thing we'll do in this
course but this proof goes to the
spectrum it goes to something beyond the
physical domain okay that's it's neat
but I want to show you a different proof
that stays within the physical domain
and this other proof I mean it's always
nice to see some different proofs
because you can use it to apply to
different situations and there are some
situations where you might not be able
to use this spectral spectral
characterization for example what if
your K 3 is now OK for similar
inequality is true but this proof
doesn't show it at least not directly
you have to do a little bit of extra
work so let me show you a different
proof of the upper bound and we'll prove
a slightly stronger statement namely
that for all not just square phones but
it's not so important but for all
symmetric measurable functions from the
Union Square to R 1 has the following
inequality namely that the K 3 density
in W is upper bounded by the K 2 density
of W squared raised to power
three-halves here the square is meant to
be a point wise square
so a couple of things if you were graph
is a graph on a graph then or if it's a
graph then 0 comma 1 value so taking
this point my square doesn't do anything
if you're graphing you can always put
one more inequality that replaces it by
the thing that we're looking for because
W is always bounded between 0 and 1 so
it's a slightly stronger inequality okay
and let me show it to you by writing
down a series of inequalities and
applying the Cauchy Schwarz inequality
repeatedly so it's again in exercise in
using Cauchy Schwarz and we will apply
three applications of Cauchy Schwarz
essentially three applications one
corresponding to every edge of this
triangle so let me begin by writing down
the expression in griffons corresponding
to the k3 density okay I'm going to
apply Cauchy Schwarz by so I'm going to
apply Cauchy Schwarz to the variable X
holding all the other variables constant
so hold dy and DZ constant going to
apply to DX you see there are two
factors that involve the variable X so
apply Cauchy Schwarz to them you split
each of them into an l2
so one of these factors become that by
the way all of these are definite
integral's I'm just omitting the domain
of integration so all the integrals are
integrated over from zero to one so the
second application or so the second
factor becomes that and the third factor
is left intact
okay so that's the first application of
cauchy-schwarz you apply with respect to
DX to these two factors split them like
that thank you there is a normalization
missing yeah okay guess what the second
step is we're gonna apply Cauchy Schwarz
again but now to dy one more variable
Toshi shorts with respect to dy there
are two factors now that involved the
letter Y so I apply Cauchy Schwarz and I
get the following the first factor now
just becomes the l2 norm of W the second
factor does not involve Y so it is left
intact and the third factor is can't
integrate it with respect to Y after
taking squid
and there's now DZ that remains last
step now you can guess you integrate
with respect to DZ and apply coffee
shorts black coffee shorts to the last
two factors and they'll actually do
outside integral goes away so you get
this product and you see every single
term is just the l2 norm of W so that
which is the same as what I wrote over
here okay
any questions yeah okay great question
so where do I use the fact that W is
symmetric well so let's see in some
sense we're not using the fact that W is
symmetric because there's a slightly
more general inequality you can write
down and actually the question gives me
a good chance to do a slight diversion
into how this inequality is related to
holders inequality okay so this is
actually one of my favorite inequalities
for this kind of combinatorial
inequalities on graphics
so many of you may be familiar with
holders inequality in the following form
if I have three functions if I integrate
them then you can upper bound this
integral by the product of the l-3 norms
and likewise if you have more functions
so if you apply just this inequality
directly you get a weaker estimate okay
so you don't get anything that's quite
as strong as what you're looking for
over there so what happens is that if
you know so if F G and H each depends
only on a subset of the coordinates
in the following way that after pens are
only X&Y G depends only on X and Z and H
depends only on y and z then if you
repeat that proof verbatim with three
different functions you'll find that you
can upper bound this product this
integral by the product of the l2 norms
are two norms are in general less than
or equal to the l3 norm so here were
inside the probability measure space so
the entire spaces volume one so this is
a stronger inequality and this is the
inequality that comes up over them
great so question is you're entirely
crafty whether proof of this so the
reason why I mentioned that this result
is a special case of Crisco Kitana so
Crisco katana actually is a stronger
result which tells you precisely how
many how you should construct a graph so
Givens exactly M edges what's the
maximum number of triangles and the
statement of theorem is actually I mean
it's a very precise result it tells you
for example if you have K choose two
edges you have at most K choose three
triangles it's not just at a density
level but exactly and even if the number
of edges is not in the form of K choose
two it tells you what to do and actually
the answer is pretty easy to describe
it's almost intuitive so if you know I
give you a bunch of matchsticks and ask
you to construct a graph with as many
triangles as you can you know what
should you do you start with one two and
you're filling a triangle you know start
filling a triangle another vertex one
two three four you keep going and that's
the best way to do it and that's what
Crisco katana tells you okay so that's a
more precise version of this inequality
and the Crisco katana the combinatorial
version is proofed via a combinatorial
shifting argument also known as a
compression argument namely if you start
with a given graph there are some
transformations you do to that graph to
push your edges in one direction that
saves the number of edges exactly the
same but increases the number of
triangles at each step and eventually
you push everything into a creek that's
something you can read about it's a very
nice result other questions
all right so we solved the upper bound
and that is in the from an example isn't
from this upper bound proof we see that
it's the upper bound now let me tell you
a fairly general result that says
something about graph theoretic
inequalities in a button for specific
kind of linear inequalities so here's a
theorem due to Bala Bosch I'm interested
in an inequality of the form like so I'm
interested in inequality of this form
where I have a bunch of real
coefficients and I'm looking at a linear
combination of the clique densities I
would like to know if this inequality is
true so somebody gives you this
inequality whatever the numbers may be
you can also have a constant term right
the constant term corresponds to R
equals to 1 right so the point density
that's the constant term and asks you to
decide it's this inequality true if so
prove it if not find a counterexample
okay so the theorem tells you that this
is actually not hard to do so this
inequality holds for all G if and only
if it holds
whenever G is a clique
maybe somebody gives you this inequality
about linear inequality about Creek
densities than to check this inequality
you only have to check over all cliques
G which is much easier than checking for
all graphs right for each click G this
is just some specific expression you can
buy down and you can you can check so I
want to show you the proof of Bolla
bashas theorem it's it's a quite nice
result but before that any questions
about the statement all right so the
reason I say that this is very easy to
check if I actually give you what the
numbers are it's because this inequality
four clicks so inequality is equivalent
to just a statement but the inequality
that I'm writing down now where I tell
you precisely what the our clique
density is in n click that's just some
combinatorial expression so to check
whether this inequality is true for all
graphs I just have to check the specific
inequality for all integers and which is
straightforward
all right so let's see how to prove that
inequality up there and here we're I
mean we're not going to exactly use the
theorems about griffons but it's useful
to think about graphics so first okay so
in the if and only if one of the
directions is trivial okay so let's get
that out of the way first
but also so for the if direction first
note that this is true for all graphs if
and only if it is true for all graph
phones and where I replace G by W by the
general theory of graph limits and
whatnot this is this is true so in
particular there's one class of graphs
that I would like to look at namely I
want to consider the set of note
weighted so yeah so I want to consider
the set of note weighted simple graphs
so note weighted simple graphs by this I
mean a graph where some of the edges are
present and I have a node wait wait for
each node and to normalize things
properly I'm going to assume that the
nodes weights add up to 1 now you see
that each graph like that you can
represent it by a graph on
where so you can have a graph own
they're not meant to be the same picture
but you know you have some platform like
this which corresponds to a node
weighted graph and the set of such node
weighted graphs is dense in the space of
griffons in particular as far as graph
densities are concerned they include all
the simple graphs so it's the physis i
mean it's in its equivalent to this okay
the inequality is equivalent to it being
true for all known weighted simple
graphs but for this space of graphs
suppose that the inequality fails it's
post inequality is false then there
exists a node weighted simple graph
going to actually drop the word simple
from now on so no weighted graph H such
that half of H being the above sum is
less than zero and there could be as
many possibilities for such an H but let
me choose one among all the possible HS
let's choose one that is minimal in the
sense that it has the smallest possible
number of nodes so it is minimum
right as a minimum number of notes and
furthermore among all H with this number
of notes choose the note weights which
were to note by a1 through am summing to
1 chooses note weights so that this
expression this sum is minimized and by
compactness and now we're not even
talking about compactness space of graph
once you have a finite number of
parameters it's continuous function so
just by compactness there exists such an
H for which the minimum is achieved this
is minimizing over integers and here
minimizing over finite set of bounded
real numbers so the name of the game now
is we have this H which is minimizing
and I want to show that H has certain
properties if it doesn't have these
properties I can decrease those values
okay so let's see what properties this H
must have if it has the minimum number
of nodes and f of H is minimum possible
the first I claim that all the node
weights are positive if not I can delete
that node and decrease the number of
nodes I would like to claim that H must
be a complete graph because if some IJ
is not an edge of H so here is different
from J I don't allow loops H is simple
then let's think about what this
expression F F H should be so I don't
want write this down but I won't imagine
in your head right so you mean you have
this this graph on H I'm looking at the
creek density it's some polynomial in
fact it's some multi linear poly it's um
it's some polynomial in in these node
weights okay so I want to understand
like what is the shape of this
polynomial as a function of the node
weights an observed that has to be
multilinear
in has to be multilinear in particular
in alpha I and alpha J okay it's a
polynomial that should be clear it is
multi linear because well you know you
have okay why is it multi learning why
do I not have alpha I squared that's a
term either view okay so we're
forbidding so here's of a 1 over 2 of 3
or 4 so this understand you know what
the triangle density you know if you
write down the triangle density that's
an expression in in terms of the
parameters think about what comes out
what it looks like and they essentially
consist of you choosing a sub graph you
cannot have read please okay so it's
it's multi linear so it's multi linear
in particular in alpha I and alpha J so
so no term has the product of I alpha J
in it because I J is not an edge so so
here's what we're really using that
we're only considering click densities
I said turn up there is completely false
without the assumption of Creek
densities if we have a general
inequality general linear inequality
than the statement is completely false
so it's multi linear so if we now fix
all the other variables and just think
about how to optimize how to minimize
half a page by tweaking alpha I and
alpha J well it's linear so you should
minimize it by setting one of them to be
zero and that would then decrease the
number of nodes so can shift alpha I and
alpha J while preserving Phi plus alpha
J and not changing so not increasing f
of H and then we get either alpha is
equal to 0 or alpha J to go to zero in
which case we decrease the number of
nodes thereby contradicting the
minimality assumption ok
so this argument here then tells you
that H must be a cook so hence H is
complete and if H is complete then as a
polynomial in these alphas what should
it look like
well has to be symmetric with respect to
all these alphas so in particular it has
to be so since H is complete we see that
in fact now you can write down exactly
what f of H is in terms of the
parameters described in the problem
namely it's C R times R factorial times
SR where s r is a symmetric polynomial
where you look at you choose R of the
terms R of these alphas for each term in
this sum
it's just elementary symmetric
polynomial and I would like to know
given such a polynomial how to minimize
this number by choosing the alphas but
if you think about what happens if you
fix again everything but two of the
alphas so by fixing all I say alpha 3 to
offer n we find that so as a function in
just alpha 1 and alpha 2 f of H has the
following form
and because it's symmetric these two
bees actually the same so if we now very
alpha-1 and alpha-2 but fixing
everything else because alpha-1 plus
alpha-2 it's constant i can even get rid
of this linear part so that linear part
is as fixed as a constant I want to
minimize this expression with alpha 1
and alpha 2 plus alpha 2 how fixed so
there are two possibilities depending on
whether C is positive or negative or I
guess zero so if you're here so
depending if C is positive or negative
half it's minimized by either alpha the
two alphas equal to each other or one of
two alphas should be zero
the latter cannot occur because we
assume minimality so the first must
occur and hence by symmetry if you apply
the same argument to all the other
alphas all the alphas are equal to each
other which means that H is a simple
trick it's basically an unweighted
clique all right so in other words if
this inequality fails for some H some
node weighted H that it must fail for a
simple click H and that's the claim
above
okay question if there are two ends yeah
that's thank you so these are two yeah
so these are two different
I'll get questions why can we assume
that you can choose H so that F of HS
minimized
it's because once okay so you agreed the
first thing you can minimize because the
number of notes is a positive integer so
if there's a counter example we'll
choose the minimum counter example now
you fix that number of vertices and the
number of then this is an optimization
problem it's a minimizing continuous
function with a finite number of
variables so it has a minimum just by
compactness of a continuous function so
I choose that minimizer any more
questions okay so we have this rather
general looking theorem so in the second
part of today's lecture
after taking a short break I want to
discuss what are some of the
consequences and also variations of that
statement up there and I want to also
show you what the rest of this picture
looks like so let's continue to deduce
some consequences of this theorem up
there that tells us that it is pretty
easy to decide linear inequalities
between clique densities namely to
decided just check the inequalities on
cliques so as a corollary for each for
each n for each and the extremal points
so the extremal points
of the convex hull this set where I
record the Creek densities overall graph
phones W so so think about this set as
the higher dimensional generalization of
that picture I drew up there but no nope
previously we had N equals to 3 we were
still interested in N equals to 3 but in
general you have this set sitting in
this box and okay so it's it's some set
and if I take the convex hull of this
set what that theorem tells us and of
course maybe one bit of extra
computation but what it tells us is that
the extremal points are precisely the
points given by W equals to K M evaluate
find what this point is for each M you
have a bunch of points and those are the
convex hull so LLL astray by drawing
what the points are for the picture over
there but it essentially follows from
polar botches theorem with one expert of
computation to make sure that all of
these are actually their extremal points
of the convex hull none of them is
contained in the convex hull of the
other points so for example we can also
produce very easily
pterence theorem
so what is Tehran's theorem tell us it
tells us that if the R plus 1 density R
plus 1 click density is 0 then the K 2
density is at most 1 minus R so why does
Tehran's term follow from the above
claims it should follow because all the
data here has to do with qlik densities
and everything which so far says that if
you just want to understand linear
inequalities between Creek densities
it's super easy
maybe I draw the picture for triangles
and then you'll see what it's like so
the corollary tells us for this picture
corresponding to N equals to 3 what the
points the extreme points of the convex
hull are so maybe let me draw these
points for you so one of these points is
it's 1/2 comma 0 so that corresponds to
men-tel's theorem now if you go to the
other values of M you find that those
points so the extreme points they are of
the form n minus 1 divided by m m minus
1 and minus 2 divided by M Squared for
positive integers
M okay so for m equal stitute that's the
point that we just drew and the next
point okay so next two points one-third
and 1/4
they are at if you plug it in
so - thank you 2/3 and 3/4 they
correspond to two nines and in 3/8 so
let me show you where these points are
so they are at here and over there and
you have this sequence of points going
up so this is the convex hull and from
that information you should already be
able to deduce men-tel's theorem right
because this right half is not part of
this convex hull so that's one man tells
theorem is and similarly the deduction
the tehran's theorem also follows by a
similar logic so okay so you have this
sequence of points now it happens that
all of these points lie on a curve so
let me try to draw what this this extra
curve is ok so there's some curve
there's some curve like that the
equation of this curve happens to be X
2x minus 1
and because the regions is contained in
the convex all the yellow points it has
certainly lies above this convex red
curve you've seen this red curve before
from where
so what is the same saying that if your
edge density is beyond above 1/2 then
you have some lower bound on the
triangle density where have we seen this
before problem set 1 there's a problem
problem set 1 that says exactly this
inequality so go back and compare what I
did ok but of course the the convex hull
result helps you even a little bit more
right namely that you can draw line
segments between these convex hull
points so you have some polygonal region
there lower bounds the actual region ok
so what is the actual region so leaving
you in suspense but so let me tell you
what the actual region is now so it
turns out to be actually it's beautiful
and it's quite deep that the region is
now completely understood and it's a
fairly recent results only about 10
years ago roughly that there are some
concave curves the sequence of scallops
going up to the top right corner and
this is understood to be the complete
region between these lower and upper
curves so this is the complete set of
feasible regions for edge versus
triangle densities ok so this lower
curve is a difficult result due to rasp
or off and I want to just give you a
statement what what this curve is and
grasp or off came up with this machinery
this technique now by the name of flag
algebra so he came up with his name
so I won't really tell you what flag
algebra is but it's kind of a
computerized way of doing cauchy-schwarz
inequality so many of our proofs for
these craft weather inequalities they go
through some kind of cauchy-schwarz or
sum of squares equivalently but there
are some you know very large or
difficult inequalities you can also
prove this way but it may be difficult
to find exactly what is the actual
inequality the chain of Cauchy Schwarz
or the sum of squares that you you
should write down so this machinery flag
algebra is a language is a framework for
setting up those sum of squares
inequalities in the context of proving
graph theoretic inequalities so it can
be used in many different ways and
notably a lot of people have used
serious computer computations if I want
to prove something is true I plug it
into what's called a semi definite
program that allows me to decide what
kinds of cauchy-schwarz inequality I
should be applying to derive the result
I want to prove so that's what flag
algebra roughly is so what Ross Perot
proved is the following ross perot's
theorem which is strong up there that's
the lower curve is that for fixed okay
so for a fixed value of edge densities
if it lies between two specific points
drawn the ball
the minimum value of triangle density
with that fixed value of edge density is
obtained via the following construction
it's attained by the step function graph
on corresponding to to a K clique so a
complete graph on K vertices with node
weights now 4 1 3 over K sum into 1 and
such that the first K minus 1 of the
node weights are equal and the last one
is smaller all right and the point here
is that if you are given a specific edge
weight edge density then there's a
unique choice of these alphas that
achieved that edge density and that is
the graph on you should use that
minimizes the triangle density describes
the lower curve you can write down
specific equations for the lower curve
but it's not so important this is a more
important description these are the
graphs that come out and what is
something that is actually quite I mean
part why you should suspect this theorem
is difficult is that unlike Tehran's
theorem right appearance term which
corresponds to all those discrete points
interest or the minimizer is unique I
tell you at the number I tell you that
the edge density is 2/3
I want me to minimize the number of
triangles nothing turns there but it
turns out that this extremal point is is
unique essentially corresponds to a
complete three-part a graph
before the intermediate values the
constructions are not unique so unless
the k2 density is exactly of this form
the minimizer is not unique and the
reason why it is not unique is that you
can replace okay so so what's going on
here so you have this graph on for 1
alpha 2 alpha 3 I can replace this graph
on here by any triangle free graph all
of the same edge density and there are
lots and lots of them and the non
uniqueness of the minimizer makes this
minimization problem much more difficult
so ross perot proved this result for x
verses triangle densities and this
program was later completed to k4 and
more generally to kr so k4 is due to a
result of Nikki for off and the kr
result of right so a similar picture
it's more or less that picture up there
but with the actual numbers shifted if
instead of H versus triangle it is now H
versus kr I should say that it's worth
this is a picture that I drew up there
and this is roughly the picture you see
in textbooks
you know how they draw this these
scallops I once plot
what this picture looks like in
mathematica just to see for myself what
the actual graph is and it doesn't
actually look like that the the concave
nurse it's very subtle if you draw on a
computer they look like straight lines
so in some sense that's a cartoon right
so the the concave nurse is charactered
so it's not actually as concave I said
they're strong but I think it's a good
illustration of what's happening in
reality okay questions so on one hand
every polynomial graph inequality well I
mean by polynomial graph inequality so
something like suppose I have some
inequality of this form so and I want to
know is this true
it turns out that I don't actually need
these squares in some sense because I
can always replace them by what happens
if you take disjoint unions so all I'm
trying to say is that every polynomial
graph inequality can be written as a
linear graph in equality of densities
but nevertheless this still captures a
very large class of graph inequalities
and if I just give you some arbitrary
one that is not of that form it can be
often very difficult to decide whether
it is true or not right so over here
it's not so hard you just plug it in and
you can decide whether it is true I mean
it's turns out to decide whether this
inequality is true is it's really a
polynomial then you just you just check
it's not too hard to do but in general
suppose I give you an inequality of this
form so some generalized version of a
linear inequality like that it's an even
decidable if the inequality holds
decidable in the sense of like touring
halting problem so is there some
computer program just give you this
inequality is is it true can you write a
computer program that decides the
truthful is it turns out okay so before
telling you what the answer is let me
just put it in some context what about
more classical questions that before we
jump in to graph theory if I give you
some polynomial P over the real numbers
okay so yes and I want to check
is that true okay so this is this is not
you hard this is not too hard but you
know when if you have multivariate for
all real does anyone know the answer is
this decidable okay so yes you can
imagine these things were study pretty
classically and so it turns out that
every first warder theory over the real
numbers is decidable so this is a result
of tarski
and particular such questions are
decidable and in fact there's a very
nice characterization of so there's a
result called Alton's theorem that tells
you that every such polynomial if it is
non-negative then if and only if it can
be written as a sum of squares of
rational functions so there's a very
nice characterization of positiveness of
polynomials over the reals but now I
change the question and I ask what about
over the integers right so if I give
your polynomial is it always
non-negative if I have integer entries
what is this decidable okay so it turns
out this is not decidable and this is
related so it's more or less the same as
the undecidability of Diophantine
equations
and which is also known as Hubbard's
tenth problem so there's no computer
program where we give you a dire
fainting equation and solves the
equation or even tells you whether the
solutes whether the equation has a
solution no this is part of what makes
number theory mixed our finding
equations interesting so it's it's
undecidable value no we we can talk
about it okay so the undecidability is a
famous result due to Mathias image so
what about graph theoretic inequalities
so yes a graph homomorphism inequality
decidable
I mean the question should ask yourself
is which one is a closer to there's a
closer to deciding the positiveness of
polynomials over reals or over integers
on one hand you might think that it is
more similar to the question of
polynomials over real so first of all
why it's similar to polynomials I hope
that's at least intuitively it's I mean
nothing is a proof but intuitively it
feels somewhat similar to polynomials
and all of these guys you can write down
as polynomial like quantities we saw
this earlier in the proof of polar
Bosh's theorem so you might think it's
similar to ríos because well for
griffons you can take arbitrary real
weights so it feels like the reals so it
turns out due to a theorem of Hitomi and
noren that the answer is not it is not
decidable and roughly the reason has to
deal with this picture even though the
space of graphics is not discrete it's a
very continuous object even if you just
look at this picture here you have a
bunch of discrete points along this
scallop so here's a potential strategy
for proving the undecidability of graph
homomorphism inequalities i start by
just restricting myself to this curve I
restrict myself to the red curve if you
restrict yourself to the red curve then
the set of possibilities is now discrete
set which is like the positive integers
and now I start with I can reduce the
problem to the problem of decidability
of integer inequalities I start with an
integer inequality I convert it to an
inequality about points on this red
curve and that turns into a
corresponding graph inequality which
must then be undecidable so so this
undecidability result is related to the
discreteness of points on this on this
red curve but you know so general
undecidability results are interesting
but often we're interested in specific
problems so I'll give you some specific
inequality and asks is it true and there
are lots of interesting open problems of
that type my favorite one and also a
very important problem in extrema graph
theory is known as sidorenko's
conjecture okay so still rankles
conjecture it's a conjecture says that
if H is bipartite then the H density in
G or W is at least the edge density
raised to the power of the number of
edges of H so we saw one example of this
inequality when H is the for cycle just
when we discussed quasi randomness so we
saw that this is true in the homework
you'll have a few more so in the next
problem homework you have a few more
examples where you're asked to show this
inequality it has open we do know any
counter examples and the first open
example it's known as something called a
mobius strip
so the Mobius strip graph which is a
fancy name for the graph consisting of
taking a k55 and removing a 10 cycle so
that's the graph it is open whether this
inequality holds for that graph there
and this is something of great interest
so if you can make progress on this
problem people will be very excited now
okay why this is called a mobius strip
let's took me awhile to figure out so
there are many different interpretations
I think the reason why it's called a
mobius strip is that if you think about
the usual simplicial complex for a
mobius strip and then this is the face
vertex incidence bipartite graph so five
vertices one for each face five where
does this one for each vertex and if you
draw the incidence structure that's the
graph I'm not sure if there's
topological formulation will help you
improving sidorenko's conjecture or to
disprove it but certainly that that's
why it's called a mobius strip and there
are some people believe who believe that
it may be false it's still open
I still
the one last thing I want to mention is
that even though the inequality written
up there in general is undecidable if
you only want to know whether this
inequality is true up to an epsilon
error then it is decidable in fact
there's an algorithm that week I can
tell you so so there exist algorithm
that decides for every epsilon that
besides so I just want to know whether
that inequality is true pitaya loan
epsilon error meaning it decides
correctly that this inequality is true
up to an epsilon error for Oh G or
outputs G such that the sum here is
negative okay so up to an epsilon live
error I can give you an algorithm and
the algorithm follows I mean it's it's
not too hard to describe basically the
idea is that if I take an epsilon
regular partition then all the data
about H densities can be encoded in the
epsilon regular partition so apply even
a weak regularity lemma is no and then
we can test the bounded number of
possibilities
with some fixed number of hearts and by
the counting lemma you lose some epsilon
error if I check overall weighted graphs
on some boundary parts whose edge
weights are multiples of Epsilon let's
say whether this is true if it's true
then it is true with this epsilon if it
is false then I can already output a
counterexample
so there's only finitely many
possibilities as a result of weak
regularity lemma and therefore this
version here is decidable so today we
saw many different graph theoretic
inequalities and some general results
and there are lots of open problems
about graph homomorphism inequalities ok
so this concludes roughly the extreme of
graph theory section of this course so
starting from next lecture we will be
looking at Roth's theorem so looking at
the 4-year analytic proof of Roth's
theorem